[Music]
first of all have you chosen who you
will kiss tonight so I was looking
whoever's looking the most handsome Ryan
Reynolds gonna get another one Ryan's
here he'll have to work hard I don't
like I don't know twice I don't know to
be walking on the red carpet surreal you
know very weird it's it's too much to
compute really I'm here with how are
they handling all of this well then
ahead so just kind of like make sure I
don't fall over sweat too much or a
wardrobe malfunction so they're really
kind of supported so so they're much
calmer than I am
what has been the highlight for you so
far being nominated for the likes of
Denzel Washington and Casey Affleck you
know and Viggo Mortensen just being
being named alongside actors that
inspire me his remarkable thing okay but
what would it mean to win that out what
would it mean Rick is my dad about that
I'd be happy to be stayed in my seat all
night as the boarding and looking at the
beautiful people on stage
[Music]